[Musique]
dil des lumières et oui nous avons parlé
lumière aujourd'hui avec julien d'hier
qui est ainsi nos graf et verriers qui
offre de la couleur et de la perspective
en lumière deux verts à la ville de
chartres cet artiste illusionniste
monumental va nous expliquer le
processus de création d'une diapositive
en verre qui illumine les monuments de
la ville la nuit
[Musique]
bienvenue c'est le maître de la lumière
le maître de la lumière
[Rires]
témoin cette lumière
il n'y a que le maître de la lumière qui
puisse la lizadeel chef-d'oeuvre c'est
vraiment le maître judy ann salut julien
salingue ali n'y avaient rien à la merci
c'est normal je suis chez le maître de
la lumière forcément je rayonne julien
toi ta spécialité tu es donc artistes
illusionniste monumental tu met en
lumière des monuments avec des
dispositifs de verre c'est exactement ça
en fait nous on travaille le verre à
l'origine avec mon associé stéphane
petit on travaille le verre est à partir
de notre savoir-faire dans le vert on a
créé une nouvelle lumière la lumière de
verre qui est une lumière qui est obtenu
à partir de diapositives envers
travailler dans la masse et dans la
coloration alors on va essayer de fuir
quand même toutes les étapes de deux
créations donc là et hop numéro un donc
la première chose que j'ai fait c'est
que j'ai créé une empreinte dans
laquelle on va venir poser le vert dans
lesquelles le vert va fondre à 800
degrés va devenir visqueux et va venir
en fait vraiment cool et tout doucement
tout doucement donc ces déchets du coup
les diverses et du coup les verts savent
pas que ça c'est pas ne pas mettre sur
la croix sont quoi mais mais on se
cassera colisée étape numéro 12 d'accord
on pose le vert donc j'ai bien nettoyer
au préalable découpé au format en
belfort en route on est parti pour 24
heures et on vient voir dans 24 ans
qu'isabelle alors voilà c'est dans
l'étape peinture on est d'accord vous
faites tout à la main du coup à bas
toutes été rejetées tout est fait à la
main ça nous arrive d'utiliser des un
petit peu comme les graffeurs ont fait
part les pochoirs on parle aérographe
est un peu de grâce à un peu de gras
capuche
ou alors julien le maître de la lumière
ou est ce qu'on peut voir tes oeuvres
bon prochaine un peu partout on se
déplace un peu partout en france après
par contre si on veut vraiment avoir une
expérience immersive de la lumière de
verre dans vraiment sa version
monumental c'est tous les étés on à
l'abbaye de noirlac on crée vraiment
tout un parcours de lumière on a une
vingtaine de source sûre toute la visite
de l'abbaye qui sait de nuit donc en
rendent vraiment dans un parcours
immersif profitent aussi donc de ce choc
du temps tu vois les vieilles pierres et
la modernité la projection de vos
lumières par la lumière en fait nous on
vient faire dialoguer la pierre et le
verre quand on défende qu'on explique
tahar du verre consciemment ou
inconsciemment je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de poésie quand on parle on est
dans un art contemplatif donc senna
poésie oui c'était beau ce jeune verdon
merci de rigoler les jeunes l'équipe le
père est très cher soudain ma gueule et
ça vaut jérémy je suis touché ok
c'est que c'est cuit c'est cuit on
regarde allez c'est parti alors là ça
peut être une mauvaise surprise aux
siens il ya des fois ça marche mais j'ai
confiance est le maître de la lumière
bon c'est encore un peu bien chaud hop
on va voir ce que ça va aller
et on va voir le résultat apparaître
voir
donc là on voit le résultat du travail
je dirais
[Musique]
c'est vraiment toi le maître du verre